now let's get an independent analysis of
just what's been agreed at glasgow and
whether it will be enough to limit the
catastrophic effects of climate change
professor siddita helm is a professor of
energy policy and economics at oxford
university
last week the uh i beg your pardon let
me
let me uh
talk to you professor helm before i go
on to anybody else
cop
um
progress or just more to use the cliche
blah blah blah
well it's a bit more of the latter than
the former if the objective at cop26 was
to keep 1.5
degrees alive
it's dead
even if for the first time ever
every country does everything that it
promised to do
we won't
be able to achieve 1.5 and i think it's
important to recognize that after 30
years of cops one after the other
in every single year for the last 30
years
nevertheless of carbon to the atmosphere
two parts we've
no breaks no hesitations every year
including even last year during the
lockdowns so if you ask the question is
cop26 you know the turning point of all
the rhetoric that was trotted out before
as before all previous cops the answer
is no it tells you this isn't going to
happen and there's a very good reason
for that which is that there is this
illusion that you know climate change is
going to be solved in the uk if only we
do stuff here it's going to be fine
we're going to be world leaders and
we're going to crack it and therefore
not avoid therefore avoid the costs as
ed miliband said of climate change no
the truth is that the future of climate
in this world will be largely determined
in places like china india sub-saharan
africa in the rain forests and so on and
if you look at this summit
even in the voluntary pledges the key
players
are not at the table
and the 80
fossil fuels which are the mix of our
energy and the globe now
there's no plan to go from eighty
percent fossil fuels to north globally
indeed that's starkly absent from the
discussions at glasgow so let's not
because what this solves solves the
problem it certainly doesn't
so what was the point of the last two
weeks you make it sound like it was just
a complete waste of time
no no it's very good that people talk
it's very good that people are educated
about what's going on but it's not good
to believe that these great summits are
the crunch point that's going to turn
the globe that isn't what these things
are about and if we really seriously
want to get in the game of no longer
causing climate change we have to get
the metrics right so it's not whether
you produce steel in britain that counts
as opposed to import it it's that there
is steel in our mix territorial carbon
emissions you can get those down by
closing down the steel industry if
that's what you want to do what matters
is our carbon consumption our carbon
footprint and that's part of trade
that's about carbon border adjustments
that's about carbon pricing all the
stuff that wasn't discussed at cop is
absolutely critical to proper engagement
so you and i can genuinely say we are no
longer causing climate change
let's come back to some of those uh if
you like other factors but just
dealing with what cop itself dealt with
a foreign station or the i think the
slogan now is cash cars uh trees and so
on
um can you make an estimate there are
various
numbers flying around but can you make
an estimate
of
what
temperature rise we're headed for
given the promises that were made
yesterday if they were all fulfilled
where would we be
well the best estimate in the public
domain
is the 1.8 to 2.4 and my guess is it's
much closer to 2.4 than it is to 1.8
and
that is really serious that's a a
dramatic
uh change which is going to happen
in this century and affect all of us um
and when we look at you know how we
affect that which is how we persuade the
developing world not to go down the
route that we've gone down in the
developed world you know the core to
this is well how are we going to help
them do it after all we put most of the
stuff up in the atmosphere what's our
contribution well let's look at what our
contribution is the amount to be spent
private and public on dealing with the
great disaster of the
destruction of the rainforests in places
especially like the amazon is less than
we wasted on track and trace in this
country
the hundred billion
which we've never lived up to in the
past is a bit more than the annual
dividend of saudi aramco and uh quite
small compared with what we spent in 18
months in this country on coronavirus
these are the sorts of orders of
magnitude
which tell you the difference between
the brave words and what really needs to
be done to help
sub-saharan africa india indeed even
china address what is the major source
of future emissions and the major
sources of damage to our rainforests and
so on
i want to come back to what you think
should be done but just
paint a picture for us
of that of the consequences of that 2.4
degrees that you
uh mentioned a moment ago
well
there are two answers to that question
there's the obvious one which is that a
hotter world is genuinely going to be
bad for
most countries around the world and
worse for some rather than others
as to the exact effects this assumes
that we know precisely how to model the
world's climate with say two three
degrees of warming in it and that's not
true
it's very complicated as to how higher
temperatures affect all sorts of things
weather patterns right through to uh the
tundra and so on whether it triggers
dramatic changes like the release of
methane from the arctic so i think the
honest answer is we don't know precisely
but there are no suggestions that it's
going to be a good thing and quite a lot
of suggestions it's going to be a bad
and perhaps very bad thing
let me put an alternative point of view
to the one that you've been putting to
me um
the prime minister says that britain's
well on its way to net zero and we don't
need a hair shirt
to achieve it
wouldn't it be lovely if cake isn't
really was true but you can have all the
smarties and it isn't going to cost you
anything at all
let's be straightforward about this
we're taking a carbon intensive economy
and in uh
14 years we want to get rid of 75
percent of emissions and in 29 years we
want to get rid of virtually all of them
and you tell me it's going to cost you
very much now um in your previous
interview with ed miliband he was
careful to say that the costs
are less
than the cost of no not acting that's an
admission there are a lot of costs
and we should be honest you should tell
the truth you know if you've got to take
your boiler out if you've got to change
the way you drive if you've got to
change all that stuff in your carbon
diary every day of the stuff you consume
if you've got to do all that the idea
that
you know we're living beyond our carbon
means we're not paying for the pollution
because suddenly we're going to pay for
the pollution because and by the way the
price is going to be zero this is
nonsense and the way to think about it
is to think what the carbon price would
have to be to hit the target which by
the way would be one of the most
efficient ways of getting there it's not
naught so there are substantive costs
out there there is going to have to be
some change on the demand side and our
lifestyles as well as changes on the
supply side but you know hoping the
technological troops are coming down the
hill rapidly to save the day you know 29
years away is not really long enough for
much technical change
we've got to do it with what we've got
and
235 so what new technology do you think
will be on the system in 235 that's not
on the system today which is going to
make a substantive difference not a lot
okay
professor let me lastly just put um this
this to you
uh
it's all very well
uh politicians would say
for the professor
of this that and the other at oxford
university to describe the perfect
scenario and tell us we've got it all
wrong but you don't have to sell this to
voters who are going to have to pay
this is unrealistic politically isn't it
yeah
i completely agree with you right and
what that tells you is it's not that our
politicians are become some kind of
villain of the police piece it's not
that politicians don't understand the
nature of this problem they do the point
is that you and me the public don't want
to pay the cost so if you ask the public
would you like to do something about
climate change they get it that's and
glasgow's really helped in that process
to really understand this is a really
serious problem
no doubt about it the opinion polls show
that if you ask them would you like to
pay or would you like cheaper regional
air flights um or or would you like um
uh you know to have airports further
subsidized would you like not to pay
extra fuel duty
that's awesome
what it tells you is okay why climate
change is so hard to crack
is that actually we and it's ultimately
you and me that consume this stuff the
polluters don't actually want to pay
and you know that's a nasty political
reality which has to be confronted but
just simply giving people what they want
and telling them that they can have
cake-ism
that isn't leadership that doesn't help
this is a really serious problem and we
need to get on
professor helm thank you very much
indeed